de saint-quentin-en-yvelines procéder à
sa séance d'installation un nouveau
président et ses vice-présidents et est
élu un collectif de citoyens a saisi la
justice dénonçant notamment la violation
du principe de publicité de la séance le
10 mars le tribunal administratif de
versailles a décidé de l'annulation de
cinq et délibérations dont l'élection du
président et de ses vice-présidents
écouter on est satisfait parce que parce
que c'est aussi au delà de la décision
ça montre qu'il est nécessaire vraiment
que tout le monde se remette autour de
la table et qu'on arrête de manière très
claire des méthodes de travail
nous ça fait des mois qu'on demande à
skis et les chartes de bonne gouvernance
pour savoir où on va dont on part où on
va et comment
et ça nécessite de réfléchir ensemble et
c'était pas vraiment l'ambiance jusqu'à
présent donc on espère que ce jugement
va ramener chacun à la raison et
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer sur
le sujet pour l'instant dans l'attenté
de la notification du tribunal
administratif
elles disposent d'un mois pour faire
appel de cette décision